sorting algorithms are used regularly in
computer science and programming. In this course,
you will learn how the most popular sorting
algorithms work using diagrams and code.
Coding time with coding cleverly, but this time,
we're on a different channel. That's right, coding
cleverly is being featured by Free Code Camp.
This video will be about some of the different
sorting algorithms that you can apply to almost
any programming language. The language focused in
this video will be c++, however, like I said, you
can apply the concepts to any other languages of
your choice like Java, Python, C, and so on, you
would at least need to know the fundamental core
concepts of programming, especially the basic
programming constructs, like sequence selection
and iteration. To understand this video, Also,
make sure to check out my channel coding cleverly,
where I've covered almost every concept from
programming fundamentals, to object oriented
programming all the way to data structures and
algorithms and beyond. Okay, so let's start by
writing a simple algorithm for sorting an array.
So first of all, let's include our iostream and
encourage you to type along with me to get the
maximum practice. So ash include iostream. And
then we have our namespace standard. And then we
have our integer main. And we also have our return
zero right here. So we're going to start off with
a very simple algorithm. And we're going to look
at its visual implementation. So suppose we have
an array of four elements. And that's the four
sides we have 231, and five. And basically, this
is an array, which is basically indexed having
values from zero all the way to three. So our job
is to sort this in ascending order, we know that
this is not in ascending order. So we're going
to use a very simple algorithm. And I'm going
to create, actually the implementation here. So
then after that, we go back to our code editor,
and we're going to type along, and it's just going
to make much more sense. So suppose we have two
variables, and we're going to have one variable,
which is going to be enlisted on the top, so we're
going to have that as AI. So that is going to be
the first one, which is zero location. And then
we have j, which is going to be the second one,
which is going to be i plus one. So right after
the AI is going to be the J and we're going to
play apply actually a nested for loop. So first
for loop is going to have some condition, though
after inside, there's going to be a premonition
that says j is less than I. So over here, what it
means is that the array of that j m, the value of
that j is less than the value of that I now that's
what I meant by array sub j and less than arrays
of absolute value of j less than the I value, this
is our condition that's going to be inside of our
nested for loop the internal one. And this is the
condition if it's true, we're going to create a
temporary variable, and we're going to store the
value of i so whatever's in it, so in this case,
it would two is in it. So two is going to be
stored in temp, so then we're going to swap it
using a swift same swapping methodology is equal
j and j is equal to temp variable. So whatever the
temp value was actually was if value is value
was two, that's going to be in J. So actually,
we just implemented a swap methodology here. So
right after that, we're going to check in this
condition. So in this case, we have two and three,
so a value of three is actually greater than the
value of two. So in this case, the condition
won't be true, and it won't execute. So this is
just going to skip the value. And we're just going
to make our j now increment to the next portion.
So we're going to skip this. So I just crossed
this out. And now I go and put this next pointer
over here and J. So now I n j, now you can
see that j is value is less, now we have one
and we have a comparing with two. So g one is
less than two. So this condition is now true,
you could see that one and two are going to be
located talking about the values. And now that the
condition is going to be satisfying here. So we're
going to look over here that temp is equal to i,
and then we have the value which is I so what is
I to so that's going to be in that temp variable
is equal to j now j is actually one, so i is equal
to one, so we're going to have here i is equal to
the value one. Now after this we have j so j is
equal to Now the value of temp. Now temp value was
actually two. So now you can see that this
swapped value. So we have I, which is now one
except for two now two, and now over here in the
J position instead of one. Now we have the value
of two. Now you can see that swapped out and now
Jays value going to be incremented. So you can
see that the index is now no longer going to be
here. And now it's going to be in the fifth Bay
actually the last one, which is where the fifth
value is. And we're going to be checking again
we're gonna say i and j will say j is less than
I, well, no, it's not j is greater than I. So
now this portion of that nested for loop will
be terminated. And what what's gonna happen
now is our eyes are going to be incremented.
So I plus plus, and we're gonna have I know,
plus one. So originally where j was right, so
now there, that's where i is going to be. And
actually, what we see here is that j is always
going to be i plus one, like we mentioned before,
this is our sorting algorithm process that we
need. So it's just going to be side by side,
or they're going to be a jacent to each
other in initially, and then after that,
they're just going to be incrementing. So like,
just like Jays position, so we have j over here,
and we have i and j. So if I look over here,
we have I, which is three and J, which is to
check the condition. Now that's true
again. So what's going to happen
is that j is less than i that is true. And we're
going to process this temp is it, temp is equal to
Now you could guess what's happening
here. Now temp is equal to the value of i,
which is three now, so three is going to be placed
here. So there you go, three. And then after that,
we have i is equal to Now the value of j, j is
actually two, so we just gonna have two over here,
i is equal to two. And then last one, which is j
is equal to the value of 10 plus 10, plus three,
so that places over here, so now we just basically
swapped it again. So we have instead of three,
we have two over here, and instead of two, we
have three over here. So you can see now that j
is now going to be incremented, again to the last
one, and we can see i is just in the same exact
position, and zero is going to compare two and
five. Well, that condition is not satisfied for
this condition, so is just going to increment that
process again, i and j now is going to compare
and say three and five, while that condition is
also not true for that while loop to be executed.
So now we have this i and j in red. So you'll
see that there's nothing to be changed.
So we have actually, our algorithm is working.
And we see that 123 and five, see 123 and five,
there are in ascending order. And that's how our
algorithm was supposed to work. So this visual
implementation of this algorithm helped us and now
we could map this into our code. So we're going to
be right now typing, so I would encourage you
to type along with me. So let's just get things
started. Okay, so the thing here is that we're
going to have to create an array, and I call it
an array, and I suppose one is have a size. So I
could define something over here on the top. So I
say hash define, and I say Max, and I say that's
the 100. Alright, so this is the maximum value,
so it just put max here. And what I could say here
is that, I could ask the user to enter a number
and, and that will be the size and it
should be in between zero to 100. So
it's going to be input, and then it's going
to be n now I need to define an N here,
so I'm just gonna say integer. And so this is
the integer and now inputting values in an array.
So in putting values in array with a new for,
don't say int i is equal to zero is less than n,
I would say i plus plus really simple. And then
we have the RAND function that's going to put
values randomly inside of the each indices, so we
could say array sub, I would say, just the RAND
function. And that's it. So this is going to give
a number between zero to the RAND Max, whatever
the integer Max is. So what we could put here is
now we just have to include one more header file
for the RAND function. So it's called C standard
library. And there you go. So C standard libraries
don't know we have values inside of this,
let's output our array. So outputting
the unsorted array, so unsorted array, we would
just basically say for int, i is equal to zero,
i is less than n, and then we have i plus plus,
and then we say console, output array sub sub i,
and we put this space. And hopefully, we'll get an
array just put an end line right here at the end.
And now I save my code. So I'm going to run it
using my G plus plus compiler. So over here,
I'm going to be writing g plus plus my name, which
is part one, and we have CPP, and hopefully, it's
going to be compiled. Now we just say a to run it,
and through a number n. So basically, I could say
10. Now it's going to give me 10 random
numbers for my eight array. So it has 41,
this, this and this and all the way to 10. So
you can see that these are 10. Let's run this
one more time. And now I'm going to input 20.
Now it's supposed to give me 20 random integers.
So now though, there you go. How about having
50 no 50 random integers. Now you got my point
over here. It's creating a randomized array. And
putting some random values. But you could see over
here that these are not sorted in any kind of
order. They're not in ascending node or are in
descending. And our that's our job to put that. So
it's a 41. And you can see that this is a number
that's greater, but then after that you can see a
smaller number. And what does this even meaning.
So we need a properly managed array. So let's
create a properly managed array. So what we
can do here is right after this, let's create
a sorting algorithm. So sorting, and array. So
how are we going to sort this array? First of all,
let's go and open a for loop. So let's say for
int i is equal to zero, i is less than n, and then
we say i plus plus. And then right after this,
we can put on another input array. So we could
say, this another loop, that's going to be
nested inside of the beginning one, so it's
going to be J. But this is careful. This is
the next value after the array. And I'll tell you,
what's the reason behind this, say j less than n,
and we say j plus plus. And now inside of this is
basically our concept that's going to be applying
with array sub j is less than array sub i. Now
what does this mean? I'll tell you all of this.
So suppose we have an array. And that says that
if array sub j is less than arrays, because
look at this, so this is an array,
and you will see that it's an order.
So you can see that this is this I value which
is starting from zero, and this is a j which is
starting, which is greater than I want one times,
so you'd see that j is this. And this is now
if I had a randomized or raise, oh, let's say five
over here. So you could see that this is not in
ascending, it's basically 10. And then it's five,
why is five over here, something bigger should be
appearing. So the condition here is that erase
sub j is less than array sub i. So meaning if
array sub j, which is this is less than array sub
i. And that is the case. Now what we want to do,
we want to swap the values. So what we could
do by swapping the values, so var five could
be over here, and the original value 10 should
be placed over here. How do we do this, because
510 30 and 40 will be then sorted. And the thing
is that we're going to have to create an input
integer, temporary, something. So we're going to
put that in assign that with I. Now once we have
that assigned with I now what we could do here is
that we could change a race of AI. And we could
say to that to a race of J. So we're assigning a
race of eyes value with array sub J's value. And
now we can have a race of J's value. And we'd like
to put that as a temp value. So this is going to
improvise our array in a sorted fashion. And it's
going to be in ascending order a sc n di, N D, or
D er. So this is going to be in ascending order.
So it's going to check and then after that, it's
going to do this, it's going to go into our next
iteration, which is going to be is equal to one.
So plus plus increments to this,
so it's going to be this value,
and then it's going to be checking with this
value. And it's going to see if it's the case
that it's not right, it's going to swap it
out, it's just going to next, do this
next iteration until the array is done
examining. So once it's done, you can just break
out the loop. And once your break, like your free,
so what's once you're free, you return to
zero. So this is going to give me my array in
ascending order. But now we don't have anything
displaying it. So let's display this array. So
I'm just going to write comments shorting
the array, now we're going to display
the, so let's just say the sorted array.
So displaying the sorted array, we just
do a basic for loop, i is equal to zero, I'm
gonna say i less than n, and we say i plus plus.
And then over here, which we could add is
basically console output, and we say array sub
i. And then we say this. And now let's just put
an end line right here. Now let's run the code. So
basically go back to our G plus plus compiler. And
we're going to be running our code. But first of
all, let's compile it. And I'm just going to give
a hyphen o flag to indicate that this is a new
executable, and I'm just going to call it run. So
I'm going to hit the compiling button compiling is
successful. Now we're just going to run. So now
you'll see enter a number and so enter a number
and meaning that let's just enter some random
number and it's going to create an array with
some randomized values in each indices, so
let's have 20. Now these are 20 random numbers.
You will see over here for 2041 and all of this
which is unsorted. It goes in random order. And
then after that, it sorts it. And you can see my
sorting algorithm does the trick and sorts them in
ascending order. That's pretty amazing. Okay,
now let's do one other thing for us to have a
descending order fashion. One other thing I want
to do here is that, I want to tell that this is
going to be the sort of, so I could just write a
console output, and I'd say sorted. So sorted. And
right here displaying the sorted array. And the
other thing that I want to do is I just want to
show you how descending works. So this less than
sign, which is arrays of J, less than arrays of
I will just be turned into arrays of j greater
than arrays of I. So if it's greater than swap it,
so that's basically descending order, so I'm
just gonna change this ascending to d, e, s, e,
n, di, N, G. So this is now going to be
in descending order. So it's going to run
again. So I'm just going to compile this
basically. And then we're going to run it.
And now let's have a value like 22. Now
you have these values, which are 41.
And all of this in random order. And then
after that you call the sorted basically
prompted out on the terminal screen. And then
after that, you sort them in descending order
fashion, and look how awesome that took. So that's
it with this one. And now let's continue with
the other sorting algorithms. So the next sorting
algorithm is called the selection sort one of the
most common and most famous, well known sorting
algorithms in the world. So how we're going to
implement this is basically first type along,
and we're going to be explaining side by side,
as well as gonna give a brief explanation at
the end. So just keep on typing along with me.
So hash include, we're gonna have input output
stream, and then we're gonna have using namespace
standard. And then we also have integer
main. And we also have the return zero.
Now, what we're going to do here is basically,
first we're going to create a swap function.
So what I'm going to be implementing is basically
a swap function, so void, and then we have swap.
And then we have basically an array we're going
to have, and it's going to be swapping. So
I'm going to show you that it's going to have an
x value, and it's gonna have a y value. So it's
going to be implementing that famous swap function
process that we've been doing. So what's going to
be doing is basically, integer temp is going
to be having a sub x as the first value, so a
sub x, so a sub x is going to be equal to a
sub y, and then we're gonna have is a sub y
equals to the 10th. variable. So and that's how we
swap something. So suppose we have an array inside
of it, and we just call it an array. And we're
going to have some values to it. So let's say
some random values. And what we want to do is
basically, we want to swap the process over here,
if we have some random values that are
not matching, and we want to swap them,
we could use a swap function like just we did in
the basic algorithm in the beginning where we did
ascending order. So basically, we're implementing
selection sort. So we created our first function,
which is swap, the second function that we're
going to be doing is basically the selection
sword. So how this is going to go is
basically we're gonna have a void.
And we're going to call this as a selection sort.
And it's going to have two input parameters. First
one is going to be the array, and the second one
is basically going to be the size of the array.
Now inside of this is going to have the location
index, which is zero, it's going to always start
from zero array start from zero, just that and
now after that, it's going to loop through this,
so it's going to be i less than n minus one,
we're going to loop to the last the last element,
so n minus one is the last element, and then
we're going to have to find the value that
should be smaller than the value that we're
specifying as is zero, and it should be like
swapping the function, so we're going to have
to indicate one j over here. So it's going to be
called, and we're going to use another function,
which is going to be called location of smallest.
And don't worry, I'm going to be teaching what
this is. So basically, we're gonna have a sub i,
and we're gonna have n minus one. So we're
just gonna have three input parameters, here,
we're gonna have the array passed in, and you
know, this is passed by reference. So it's always
going to be the same array no matter where you're
going. And then we have iron, which is going to
be the current location, it's always going to be
incrementing. And it's going to be zero over here,
it's going to be changing. And over here is the
ending point. So that's the last one ending last
element. So swap is going to be implemented here.
And it's going to have three input parameters just
like we did before. So it's going to have the
array, which is small a, and then it's gonna
have the size of the eye and it's going to have
this J. So basically, I which is going to be
the index, so it's going to be the first element
and second element and wants to swap them. So it's
going to be implementing the swap function and
it's going to be incrementing i plus plus here.
So this is how it's going to be doing now we need
here is the location of smallest function. So that
doesn't make it oh right here. So what we're
going to do here in the location of smallest
is basically have a return type. Hello, okay,
because it's going to be returning a value of
J. So you can see that j is integer, so it needs
a return type at the end. So over here location
of smallest, let's have some input parameters, the
first input parameter is the array. And the second
parameter is the s. And the third input parameter
is the ending point. And you might be asking why
I did this. And you can see over here that the
starting point is going to be I, the ending
point is going to be n minus one. So it's always
going to be checking at the end. So it's going to
be looping through this whole array and trying to
find the smallest. And when it finds the smallest
from I, then it's gonna swap the values in the
swap function. And that's how we're going to be
implementing this selection sort algorithm.
So if I'm going to create an AI over here,
I'm just going to create intermediate intermediary
variables. One is going to be Isaac s, so I S. So
AI is going to be as the starting point, and then
we're going to have j, which is going to equal to
basically I not s, so we're going to implement
it, and we're going to say whatever it is,
that's going to be in j and I over here is the
starting point. And then what we're doing here is
that basically, we're gonna have a loop again. So
while we're gonna have i less than or equal to E,
which is the ending point, now, if A and then
we have a sub i, which is the first element,
if that is less than a sub j, if we find some kind
of thing that is greater, so a sub j is greater.
So we would say is j is equal to, I just
want to swap right, we want to locate it.
And then after that, what we want to do is
basically increment it using i plus one,
right, so that's going to be incremented. And
then we're going to return the value object.
And don't worry, I'm going to be explaining
this through a graphical representation.
So you're This is how it's done. So we have
our three functions, we have a swap function,
and we have a location of smallest function. And
we also have a selection sort function, let's
create a display function to display the contents
of the array. So it's going to be called display,
it's going to have an integer array, and it's
going to have a size of the array, which is n.
And what you're going to do here is
basically it's going to start from
zero. And what how it's going to be implementing
is basically while the i is less than n,
and then we're going to be displaying
the contents of the array by using a
sub i. And we're going to have the double quotes
over here, which is space and just going to,
it's going to keep on listing them out. And then
it's going to print an endline over here just to
make the format a little more prettier. So right
after that, what we'll do is basically have the
array over here specified, let's just create an
array, which is going to be called arr. And it's
going to have some random values. So it's going
to have 100 to 12, I'm just giving random values
over here, it's just in random format needs to be
sorted using my selection sort function. So I'm
just gonna pass this in. So you can see that this
is random. And now what I'm doing is basically
calculate the size, how to calculate the size,
one of the process I want to use is basically
the size of operator size of operators is going to
pass in, and it's going to have an array, and then
it's gonna have the size of basically the integer
variable. So basically, you will see that this is
the data type, and it's going to be for the array
is basically the whole thing. So we'll see 1234567
and eight and nine, nine, multiplied by
four, which is basically 36. And now 36
will be basically divided by the integer, which
is going to be four. So 36 divided by four
is going to give you the value, which is nine.
So nine is going to be the answer right here.
So once this is the size, I'll just comment over
here and say size equal to nine. Why don't we want
to do here is basically we want to implement our
selection. So first of all, let's just display
it. So let's just display and we're just
going to pass in the variable and the size.
So it's just going to automatically display
because it's a void function, and its purpose
is to display it. And then right after that, this
is called our selection sort of function. And it's
going to ask for array and also a size. And then
after that, we'll just display our selection,
sorted array using array, and then when you have
size. So once I do this, I'll just execute and
running. So basically, I'm going my terminal
screen over here, I'm going to write g plus plus,
I'm going to use the selection sort dot cpp. And
all we know that by default, it's going to be a,
so I'm just going to run it and I'm going
to say Oh, and I'm going to say selection
sort. So now it's compiled, and I was running
through a selection sort. Now you'll see over
here, we have some random stuff what's
going on. Okay, so something went wrong
Ctrl T, to break the code, something went wrong in
this code, and let's just check what it's wrong.
What's wrong in this. So we have iOS and then we
have it's incrementing. So this is processes okay.
And minus one is okay, there's some infinite
loop that's been created using selections
or array and then size. And so let's just look
over here. Okay, so I forgot to increment this i
plus plus. So just right here, I didn't
commit. And now it's going to be working. So
basically, we were done that, and
let's just run this code once again,
selection sort. And now let's call us and look
at that, we had this array, which was unsorted,
which is 102 12 193 90, whatever 32. And now,
what we did is passed in the selection sort,
and it's sorted the array for us, I mean, 11 1239,
in ascending order, now ascending, what is that,
like, if you have the same value, it could be
equal, or asked to be greater. So just in case,
if I have a value, like 11, and 11, they're gonna
be in the same adjacent locations. And then after
that, it could be a bigger value. So that's
sorted. In selection sword, I really hope you
enjoyed and you understood, so what I want to
do is, one other thing is basically show you
how the implementation is done. So suppose that
there are arrays sorted like this in the memory.
So we have some kind of indices. So we have
like five, and we have four, and we have three,
we have seven, we have nine. So we want to sort
this in ascending order. So what we're gonna do
by default, with selection, sorting does is that
it sort makes this eye as the index of zero,
and it will check for J. So what my process here
is like that location of smallest will be called.
And you will see in my code, which is basically
in here, so I'm just going to show you over here,
what I see here is that the location is
zero, and the Y is not less than n minus one,
the last element, what we do is we get the J
and we put that in the location of smallest
passing a, we have the I variable, which is
basically going to be zero and n minus one,
which is the last element, and it's going to
be the location of smallest. So location of
smallest is going to locate for the variable,
which is going to be this smallest one,
even i less than equal to E if it's less
than or equal to. So if it finds it,
it's going to sort that as j and it's
going to return that value. So you can see
what's happening is that it find the smallest.
So you see that the smallest here is three,
so j is going to be pointing here. And then it's
going to be applying that sorting algorithm, which
is going to cut swap this. So you can see over
here that it's going to be swapping, so we have
three over here. And then initially five is
going to be over here. But what we want to
see here is that in this text editor is that
this is basically displaying so we have a
selection sort. And then once we go back into our
selection sort algorithm, we have a swap function
swap is going to get this value by energy that's
returned from here, and it's going to swap it. So
basically the simple swap algorithm, it's going
to swap the both values. And then after that,
it's going to increment and it's going to go to
our next location. So you can see the place over
here is going to No, not, it's not going to be
pointing over here anymore. And it's going to be
pointing over here. And now this j is not going
to be over here. So just want to indicate that
this j will now going to be pointing somewhere
else. So we have this is now implemented over
here. So I'm going to be incremented over here.
Now this is going to be its base. And what we're
going to be checking now because this is not
going to be sorted with three. So now we're always
basically over here. So now we're going to look
for a value that is going to be smaller than
four. So basically, is there something for smaller
than four, it's not so that we just increment,
and we say I is going to be over here. Now
it's five, if there's something foreign,
it's okay, so it's going to be checking
all and is going to go throughout the loop
until the whole array is sorted. So I hope you
understood this concept of selection sort through
this graphical implementation. Now we're going
to go to our next sorting algorithm. And let's go
towards it. Alright, so now let's look at another
sorting algorithm. This is called the bubble sort
algorithm. And it's going to go as follows.
So basically, you have to include your input
output stream, and you're gonna have to do your
namespace standard. And let's just go simply
write our boilerplate code. Okay, so, boy,
this bubblesort is going to also deal with
swapping. So we're gonna have to include this
swapping methodology, which is basically swap,
and then we have an integer array, we have an
x value, we have an a y value. And basically,
when we go over here, we have actually a
temporary, which is going to be assigned to
the first value, and then we have the first value,
which is a sub x is going to be assigned to the a
sub y value, and then the a sub y value will be
equaling to the 10th value. So this is how the
swap works. And now let's have a bubble process.
So the bubble process is a little bit different.
How it's different, is that from selection sort
that we already covered, we actually went from
the top right, so we went from the top and then
went went our way to the bottom. So in bubblesort,
we're going to go bottom to the top, so I'll
just explain it. So first, just type along. So
it's going to be bu BB le Baba. And then what what
this process is going to do is it's going to do
some specific process, it's going to get an array.
And it's also going to get the size of the array.
And we're going to go back to this a little
later. So let me just, I just wrote a signature
right now. And I'm going to go and talk about
the void bubble process. So the bubble sort
actual functions, this is the actual bubblesort
function. And what we're gonna do is basically,
it's going to have that same integer array, which
is right here, and then we have the size. And
so now over here, what we want to do is basically
start from the portion what I was saying that
bubblesort is going to be adopting. So
the bubblesort is going to say, integer I
integer i is equal to zero. And what we need
is while we have i is less than n minus one,
the last element, we're going to have bubble
process. So BB, BB le bubble, and it's going
to have the rate and the end value, which is n is
going to be the size is going to be the rate and
it's going to increment it to the weight. So it's
just going to go and increment. So in the bubble,
what we're going to have is in here, now we're
going to open it, and we want to start so the
bubble process is going to be from the I. So it's
going to start from the last element. So that's
what I was talking about n minus one is the last
element. And it's going to go like while and we
have basically i greater than zero, so i greater
than zero. And now inside of this is if we have
a condition that if a sub is now a sub
i should be less than a sub i minus one.
Now, this means that there's an A sub
II, if it's the top portion is greater.
So what you want to do is that if a
sub i is less than the ACI minus one,
what you want to do is swap it, so we're going to
swap it using this swap function that we already
have, it's going to take a it's going to take the
AI element, and it's going to take i minus one. So
that's how it's going to swap it. And we're going
to have a generically having going minus minus
because we're starting from n minus one, it's
going to go all the way to zero. So this process
should work. So now after that, we should
have our display function. And we're ready
to go. So basically display over here have an
array. And we also have the size of the array,
which is some kind of size, I will just call
it as that. And now inside of it, we need an
input. So I will just say some kind of is equal to
zero integer. And then we have the loop process,
which is going to start from i less than n. And
then soon as go, so basically is less than n and
you want to process it. So array. And then we have
the ISO value. And we're just going to keep on
going like that, until we reach our ending
point. So which is console output over here.
Yeah, just to make it a little more similar to the
previous one, I'll just change this to just and
because this one's matching here. So now let's
create an array over here. And I'm just going to
call it as integer array. And I'm just gonna
give some random elements to it. So let's
just say this. And then it is and then something
like that, this, this and 33. Okay, this is just
random stuff. Now I want to sort this, so I'm just
going to first display. So I'm going to display,
I'm going to say array and alternate my size
data type. So actually my size variable.
So I'm going to have size n over here, I'm going
to say size of n, I'm going to have the array and
I'm going to say size of and I'm going to have
the INT it's going to give me the size. Now what
I can do here is basically have the display
function call and then the sorted function,
so it's called bubblesort. So I'm just going to
name it bubblesort. I'm going to pass in my array,
I'm going to pass in my size. I'm going to
display once again. So I'm going to display array,
and then I'm going to pass in the size. Now,
I suppose to work. So let's just go to our
c++ compiler over here, just type bubblesort bbls
o r t, and we say dot cpp. And let's just name it
something like hyphen o bl s o r t. And there we
go write, compile. And there you go. It ran Whoa,
what happened over here, I think we did the same
exact mistake. So let's just go back over here
and see where we went wrong. Okay, so we just
forgot to increment on wild loops to remember
to do this. This is really important. Okay, so i
plus plus over here. So that is just loops out and
it doesn't cause an infinite loop. So over here,
and let's just go back over here to compile it,
recompile it and running it again. You can see
that my original array was 102 and then 293, and
then 1939, and all of that and then once we passed
in our bubblesort Actually sorted out sum from
1138 102. And all the way to the last element.
So that was pretty cool. Uh, sorting an array
in ascending order using bubble sort selection
sort, because the, the methodology was basically
a little bit different. So I just want to show you
how this is implemented in a graphical wait. So
so the implementation of the bubble process is
basically similar to what we did with selection
sort. But in actually reverse order, we have this
swap function that's going on, but we have this
visualization that could help us understand how
this process is working. So suppose we have some
random values, here, we have three, we have
five, we have one, we have four, and we have,
let's say three. Now, the bubble process
is going to work like this. So let me just
go over here. And now let's see. So
it's going to start from the bottom,
and it's going to compare these two values. Now it
sees that three and four now would you mean that
is basically bubbling, meaning it's liquid
portion is on the bottom and liquid portion is
basically heavier than the Bubble bubble is
lighter bubble makes it flow on the top. So
when you compare a liquid and a bubble, bubble
is lighter, so bubbles should be on the top. So
this isn't exactly the same thing. They're talking
about the weights. So for weight is heavier than
three weight, so four should be on the bottom,
and three should be on the top. So this is
one actual process, what's happening here is
that the swap function will be called, and this
is going to be changed to three. And this is going
to be changed to four. And then after that bubble
will go up over here one step level, so it's going
to go from here. And now it's going to go over
here. So now it's going to compare three and one.
So three, and one, actually, what's different now.
So you have over here is basically you
say one and three, so actually, it's okay,
so three is heavier than one. So when it's
okay, so go again, we're one in five. So five is
heavier. So basically five will go on the bottom,
and one will go on the top. Now. Now over here,
now one in three. So basically three is
heavier. So three will go on the bottom
right here. So just three is on the bottom right
here, and then the one is will be on the top.
So this is one actual bubble process.
And you'll see 1353 and four, right now,
we basically did our one process here and we
sorted till this portion, there is more processes.
And you'll need to do one more bubble process. So
again, you're going to have to go from the bottom.
So you're going to check like this. So
basically, we're going to start again,
and we're going to see the values once more. So
forgive my writing, so four, and then we have
three, and we have five, then we have three again
over here, and we have one, so now four and three,
which is heavier, it's okay, go up here, compare
these two values. Now three and five. So three and
five, actually, five is heavier. So five will go
on the bottom. So five is over here, just cross
this one out, and this portion will be having
three now. Now three and three, well, actually,
it's the same equal, so it's going to be okay, so
one, okay, so it's okay, so 13354. Now, one more
process. So after one more process, so we're gonna
have one more process. So let me just erase all
of this, how we're going to have an even one more
process. And now, this should be our final bubble
process. So there's just look at the values again,
over here, and then over here, and then over here,
and then over here. So this is one, and then
this is three, and now this is three as well.
And now this is five, this is four, so it's going
to start from the bottom, and you see that five
and four, well, five, and four, this is different,
this is heavier, so the heavier portion should be
on the bottom and the lighter portion should be
on the top. So four is going to be over here,
and then five should be over here. So five, four,
and then 3311 inch. Okay, so this is our exact
sorted array. And this is how we're going to be
sorting our array in bubblesort, a slower and it
depends on the number of inputs. So it could vary
and exponentially grow as the inputs increase. So
that was bubble process. Alright, so now let's
jump into Insertion Sort. So this is pretty much
different from the other two that we've included
right now, which one was selection sorting,
the other was bubblesort. So I would just
encourage you to type along with me. And
explanation we'll be doing side by side. So let's
just go and include this main and then let's just
go over here and then return the zero. Okay, okay.
Now, what's gonna happen here is that we're not
going to have a swap function like we did with the
other ones, what we're going to have is basically
some differences. Now, the differences is that
we're going to have an insertion sort function,
and the insertion sort is going to basically have
an array, it's going to have one more thing that
is going to be inside of it. So the first thing
that's going to have is going to be the size.
This is pretty much the similar. And one thing
here is that it's going to start from one
not from zero, like others that do because
we're assuming something and assuming is
that the assumption is basically that some
portion of the rate is already sorted beforehand.
And we just have to like insert elements B into
that sorted array, and that's how our process
is going to be done. So we're going to go and
we're going to have a while loop so that I could
tell you that it's going to go in a while loop,
it's going to go to end and it's gonna say insert
Insert ight. Now this is going to be the function
that's going to be called. And this function is
going to take in an array, it's going to take
in the size, it's going to take in the element,
which is going to be the portion that I'm going
to be talking about. And then this is going to
keep on incrementing i plus plus, right?
Like in other languages, like I is equal,
i plus one, whatever it is, man, I can't get
the plus. Right. Okay, so just like that.
So I plus plus whatever it is like that. So now
let's have the insert ICT element, how do we do
this insert, I think so let's go over here. And
after this, let's just talk about the insert it.
So this is actually something that's also void,
and it's going to have the insert element, so just
right over here, and now inside of it, we're gonna
have the array, we're gonna have, basically we're
gonna have the integer n size, we're gonna have
the integer size, which is specified over here,
we're gonna have this key variable media
intermediary variable that's going to store our
location, or basically the value of our eye. And
now it's gonna say int j, and this j is going to
be the last element of that sorted array. So the
last element of that sorted way is going to be i
minus one, because I actually after the sorted
array, and i minus one, it will be the one last
element, so we're gonna have a loop again, and
we're gonna have two conditions. For this case,
we have j is greater than equal to, we have j is
greater than equal to zero. And we also have one
more condition that j should be actually greater
than the key. So if j is greater than the key,
we're just going to keep on looping this,
so not a G j, or whatever it is a key.
So a sub j, so let me just have this eight, and
then a j over here, not just playing j, okay,
so a sub j should be greater, and then
the J should be greater than equal to,
so what's going to happen here is that eight sub
j plus one, this is going to be implementing,
and it's going to equal to j, and I hold on, I'm
just gonna teach you this, don't worry. So now
we're gonna have j is equal to j minus one, now
it's just gonna keep on decrementing, going to
the top, like a bubble sort is gonna go up and up
and up until you reach that less than equals zero,
or if a sub j is gate, basically, greater if
it's less than something like, if it's less than,
then it's gonna just break out less than the key.
And naturally, what's gonna happen here is if this
condition is false, we're gonna have a sub j plus
one or two we're trying to implement, and we're
gonna put that key thing inside of it that lost
value. And now we just have this display function,
which is going to be over here, let's just have
it over here. So void, let's have a display.
And let's have an integer array. And then let's
have the size of it. And then let's have something
which is going to be the AI, it's going to start
from zero, it's going to go basically from while
and it's going to just check that is less than
n. And then it's going to go and say our console
output is going to say AR AR, actually,
it's not AR AR, it's going to be a sub i,
and it's going to be AI. And then it's going to be
that over here, there's going to be a comma right
there. And then there's going to be an N line,
semi colon right here. And actually not this,
I don't want that I just want a semi colon. And
this is going to be incrementing. So I plus plus.
And then we're going to have a comp end line over
here. There you go. And let's just get some data
from our previous sorting algorithm. So like a
bubblesort, let's just get some of the data, just
the array portion, not anything else. So just get
this portion over here. Let's just copy this, and
it's coming here and just paste it. So I'm just
going to go here, and we're just going to paste
it right here. So the only thing I'm going to be
changing here everything is okay. I just want to
sort out using my function. So I'm just going to
call it with my Insertion Sort, actually. Yeah,
so insertion sort is going to be called. Okay, so
the insertion sort should be over here. Let's see.
Yeah, the insertion sort is right here, it's
going to go and it's gonna call this one
insert, right? It's gonna, it's gonna perform some
operation, and then it's gonna go back plus plus,
it's going to keep on doing and it's gonna keep
on calling this insert it so many times until
the thing is sorted. And then after that, we
just display it. So let's just run this code.
I'm going to go over here my ci
plus plus, and let's just clear this
screen. And let's just compile So basically,
g plus plus is short Insertion Sort dot cpp.
And then we can say, hyphen Oflag, and then say
is short. Okay, it should be working, compiling.
Okay, so there's a warning over here and 25 no
return statement and function returning non void.
25. Let's see. 25. Where are you? 25 is over
here. And there is should be something over here
insertion sort and doesn't have a return type.
Wow, should we have a void so let's just have a
void over here. And let's just go back here.
And now let's just compile it recompile it.
And there you go. Now we have an ins short,
so Insertion Sort, and if I run this,
you're going to have this sorted. So 192
290-319-3918 32 Yo, yo, yo 1138 102 293 311.
And this is also sorted in ascending order.
Now let's have the implementation. So this
is basically an array, just a random sample, and
we have 379. And somehow this is basically sorted
from here how that happened, just randomly, it
just sorted beforehand. And now our is going
to be over here. So it's going to be after that
sorted, and then j is going to actually be going
to be over here, remember, I said that it's
going to be i minus one, so this is J, and the
first process is going to happen. So if I go over
here back in my code, so my code is over here,
and if I see over here that this is going to
be the process insert, if it has an array,
it has the inside, it has an element I,
and it says a key is equal to a sub i,
so there's gonna be a variable that's gonna be
stored, and j is equal to i minus one, and it's
gonna say that j is greater than equal to zero,
and a sub j is greater than the key. So it should
be working like that. And let's see if I could
implement here, here. So we have a key variable.
So this will have a key over here. So key k, e,
y, store that value inside of it, which is going
to be something inside. So what's it going to be,
it's going to be the value of, it's going to be a
sub i. So that's four. So four is here. Now ignore
that. Now, what you're going to do is basically,
you're going to check the condition and the
condition is true, why? Because a sub j is
greater than equal to zero. Actually, if I,
if I go back over here, where am I? Okay,
so you can see that it's j is greater than or
equal to zero, it's perfect. And then a sub j
is greater than key. Now, if I talk about a sub j,
now if I talk about that, let me just see, a sub j
is basically this nine right now. And we have a
key, which is four so that j sub j is greater.
So no, no fans where we're still working.
Okay, so the work, the thing is going to still
work. If I go back over here, we're going to
have a sub j plus one is equal to a sub j.
So that means that we're going to have something
that we're going to be implementing, so a sub j
is going to be over here. So we're going to go
over here. So this is going to mean that j plus
one is this portion, and it's going to equal it,
it's going to sign this line over here. And what's
going to happen is that it's going to go minus
one, so j is not going to be here anymore. No,
it's going to go over here. Okay, so that was
now that's one process of that loop. So that's
one process of it. And let's go again. So a sub
j greater than this is greater j is greater than
equal to zero, and a sub j is greater than the
key, because the key is for nj seven. So that's
perfect. Now let's go back over here. And we see
that a sub j plus one is equal to a sub j, and we
have j minus one a process again, so whatever that
value was, so we have seven over here, that seven
is going to be now over here. Okay, so the J is
going to go up here now, and it's going to remove
it. So you can see that there is still over here
in this location. And you can see that the four
was removed, so we don't have that value anymore.
That it just changed to nine. see over here,
this is nine. And where does nine come from? It
came from here. So within seven campervan came
from here, so this is happening, so we have this
last value over here stored in our key. So that
was the purpose of the key Well, not nice key. So
now we're going to do is basically go over here.
And we're going to see a sub j plus one, and it's
going to, it's going to see this condition, is j
greater than equal to zero. Well, that's true. If
I look at that position of here, it's over here,
it's greater than or equal to zero, but it is
equal zero. So it's true. But the second condition
is not true, why a sub j is greater than key. And
actually, it's not greater. How is it not greater,
it's less than because it's true on this key
is greater. So this just terminates that loop.
And what's going to happen now is that the key is
going to be sorted inside of this, this portion
over here, which is j plus one. So that key value,
which is four is going to be over here. Now,
this four is going to be here, 3479. Well, this is
sorted. And now it's going to, it's going to move
on and this is I know a new position of i and
this is going to be a new process. So that's
how it's going to be starting,
if I look back over here.
So you can see a sub j plus one is going to key
and then the process starts again, if you want to
do it. And that's how it basically we're going to
sort it insert sort, it's going to increment its
I value again, it's gonna be a new PlayStation,
and then after that position, and then after
that we have inserted it and then the process
starts again and again and again until the
whole damn array is sorted. And then we get
this ascending order of it. So I hope you
understood this concept of Insertion Sort.
Really, if you took this concept and
overall, like, take a practice of it,
I definitely know that you can do it. So next up,
we're going to be diving into another algorithm.
Let's dive into the merge sort algorithm. So let's
just type along with iostream namespace standard
main. And the return zero semicolon. Okay, so
let's create some functions here. And let's
just explain it the way we do it. So first of
all, let's just find our way for the merge sort.
So we're going to initially have a merge sort
function. So how this is gonna work is basically
we're gonna say void, Mr g s o r t, and we're
gonna say we're gonna have an array inside of it,
and we're gonna have the size of that. Alright, so
this is gonna have another function inside of it,
it's going to call another function. And what
this process is called, is called, actually,
this is called a wrapper function, and it's going
to pass into an auxiliary function. So this is a
wrapper function. Alright, so what we'll say is,
this is merge sort, and it's going to have the
array inside of it, it's going to have the size
of that array. And it's also going to have one
other additional parameter. So additional thing is
that it's going to have the size but before that,
it's going to have one other thing, it should have
the index of the first element, so it's going to
be the array, the index of the first element, and
then the size of that, basically, size minus one.
And this is how the merge sort is going
to be over here, we're going to have that
auxiliary function called. So on the top, we can
just specify our auxiliary function, so a UXILY
function. And what we're gonna say over here
is, we just have the same void, Mr g, s, o,
r t, and now the same input parameters, where
we have an array. So we have this input array,
we have basically the start value, and we have
the end value. Okay, these are the basically
the indexes. And we call this as the
auxiliary function, or we also known as,
say, helper function. These are some of the
names we're going to use. So let's have a
base case to this. Now. Yeah, I don't
know what a merge sort is, right? Now,
we just basically drew out the thing over here.
So we have this function calls another function.
Another scenario here we have is basically
a same array. And somehow, it's sorted in
section. So you have a first part, which is
sorted, and the second part is sorted. And
what we our job here is, don't think of this as
just two arrays, this is one single array. And
somehow, we have this first part sorted, and
we have the second part sorted. And our job
is to make this sorted in one hole. And how
we could do this is the process of merge.
So we're going to use merge sort algorithm to
do this. So what we can do is, we have to know
in advance how the first part is sorted, or the
second part sorted, and we have to put a trust,
we have to put faith in one process. And
that themes process is called recursion.
And now that's what we're going to be
applying. So you're going to check,
and the process is going to go like this.
So we're gonna have this first element two,
and we're gonna check this third out this
part over here. So first, first of these two
sub arrays, and I'm gonna say two and three, which
one is greater, I mean, which one is smaller,
so basically two is smaller, so two is going
to be planted here. And then this is going to
be incremented. So this sub array index is going
to be incremented. So it's going to be plus one,
which is going to be seven now, and this part is
going to remain the same, now three and seven will
be compared. And we could see that three is lower,
so three is going to be placed in here. And now
this is going to be incremented to four. So you
could see that four and seven will be compared,
and we have four over here. So four is going to
be and this is going to be incremented to five,
so five, and seven, and five is now going
to be added. So five is going to be here.
Now, it's going to be 15, and seven, so seven is
going to be here, so seven is going to be here
now 11 and 15, you'll see 11 is smaller, so 11 is
going to be in here. So is going to be incremented
to 19. So we have 15 and 19. So now we have 15
over here. So 15 is going to be over here. And
then we have this comparative 15 is going to be in
committed to plus plus. So we have 18 and 19. So
what what is it 18. So now you can see over here,
we assumed that this part is already full now. Now
what do we do? Well, now what we're going to do is
basically, this, this last part, we're just gonna
append to the end. So that's our process here,
what we're going to do is append these 19 and
21 to the end how we're going to do this. And you
could see by this is just sorted in our ascending
order fashion. And that's what we required. And
how do we do this? And you would ask me, now,
if it was worded like this, why not just put like
a pre existing sorting algorithm like a merge,
like something like Insertion Sort selection sort?
Well, that process is going to take longer, and
this process is fairly shorter. That's the crux
of merge sort. And that's why it makes it faster.
It's much more faster as compared to any of the
sorting algorithms we've discussed so far. So now
let's go back into our code. And now start typing
along. So first of all, let's have this merge
sort and inside of this we have an array we have
this int s, we have this int E, we have a helper
function out in the condition we have a base case,
now we have this s greater than equal to E. This
is some case that's not true. It can never be
true. In this case, it will just return. So this
is our base case. And that F That you could say
that this is just not going to be true because
start is never going to be greater than or equal
to eat. That means that it's just a logical always
you have a start, which is less than equal to
E, and I'm talking about the indices over here,
and not the value. So you have a start, like for
instance, we have a start here, and we have an end
over here, obviously, these are indexes, indices
are start from zero all the way to n, right,
and the C, start from n minus one, it never does
the other way around. So that's just illogical.
And now we're going to have the implementation
Harry, we're going to find the midpoint value
of that array. So this is our function here. So
what we have to do here is basically means is, let
me just put these plots back, okay, so our process
here is, we have to find the midpoint value,
which is right here. So you can see over here,
if I observe here, that I have 1-234-567-8910 10
elements, and if I, if I go from here, like
the start value would zero index, and the
last value, which is nine, and if I divide
this way, two, I'm going to get a 4.5, right,
and I'm gonna get the integer division of it.
So I'm just gonna get a four part, the decimal
part is just going to be excluded. So we're gonna
have 401234, this is our fourth index. So this is
our fourth index right here. And what I'm going
to do here is I'm going to place that value. So
basically, this is our four index. And we're going
to, we're going to split this here. And this is
now you could see that this is our mid m, outside,
this is our m, and, and the stuff that is before
is going to be the things. So 0123 is going to
be four and then after this is 01234. So this is
five over here, and this is four, and this is our
midpoint. Now, suppose if we added something like,
had an odd number, then we'd have even cases here,
but in this case, we don't have but this still
is our process. This is how it's going to be
implemented. Go back here, and we have this mid.
And this is going to be a simple function where
we're going to do it's going to be s plus E. Now,
this is going to be the the start index
and the last index and we divided by two,
just like we discussed. And I know that's pretty,
really simple, because this is n minus one I told
you over here, and that's the last element is
indicating the last element, and it's just going
to divide it by two, which is give a 4.5 it's
going to be four because of its it because it's
an integer division. Okay, so now let's have
that Merge Sort calling you using recursion,
that what I was talking about. So it's going
to start from a, this is our starting point.
Now, careful here that it's gonna, it's this is
the array, the starting point is S, but the Met
endpoint is now M. Why because now we're going
to try to split into two sub arrays with sorted
processes. So we're going to call again. And
the second time we're going to have a array,
it's going to start from m n is going to go
all the way to the end. So it's going to be
not m but n plus one, because now we're going
to have this process additional. This over here,
we have this portion we want sorted, and we want
this portion sorted. So we're just casing we're
just discussing right now, this portion, not this,
not this thing over here, not this right now,
we're just looking at the top. So so I hope you
got the point over here that we wanted to sorted
in ascending wise over here and the sending wise
here. Okay, so back over here, we have this m
plus one. And now we call one more function. And
that function is basically the combined function.
And the combined function is going to be pretty
much something like this, we have an A array, we
have the S which is the start, we have the middle
value, which is m which is the last value, which
is e and this combined will be defined over here
somewhere. So let's have this combined defined.
So now we're going to do is basically
we're going to say void combine.
And if I have that specified here, I would
say int a, and we have this array right here,
we have an int s starting value, we have
an int and which is the middle value.
Forget that right. And then I
got the last element, which is
end. And what we could do here is that we want
a temporary buffer. And I'll tell you why just
hold on a moment. So let's just create a buffer
over here. And what it's going to do is basically
going to get some value from the heap or is going
to get some. So it's going to be able, it's
going to be a array from the heap that we're
going to get. And basically this is going to be
representing the for the total size of the merged
array, what we're talking about. And
what we're gonna do here is that
we're gonna have a kz go to S
and we're going to say while so while is over
here, and because i k less than or equal to E
and what we do here is buffer And we say buffer
sub k is equal to a sub k. And we could say k
is equal to k plus one. Now, what do you
mean by this? Now, I'll tell you what,
what this means. The thing is that we're creating
a temporary buffer that we're allocating from the
heap. And then we're going to deallocate it using
the Delete keyword. But before that we're using
it because we don't want to reassign it in that
existing array. So we want it basically stored.
And then we want something over here. So I'll
just say this portion here, b, u, s, s, e r,
this is the buffer, this portion, and this whole
thing, I'm talking about the whole thing. So this
is buffer, and this is going to be our output
array. So this is going to be the sorted array,
we're doing in two separate things. Because if we
swing just one single array, it's going to cause
complexities, much more complexities as just
copying the elements. So suppose we have this
array. So just ignore this part, because it's not
sorted right now. And we just created a duplicate
array that had all the values. So it started from
K, and it went, so it said, zero all the way to
the value. Last one. So if I go back here, you
could see that case started with a starting value,
and it was less than equal to n value. And it just
said buffer sub k is equal buffer sub k. So a sub
k, whatever the value is, where it's going to
store it in the buffer, so it just initialized
all of them, and just k plus one all the way to
the end. So just copied, made a duplicate, right.
So now after that we could do is we're gonna
have something specified here, right after this.
So once it's copied, bam, i is equal to s. Now
we're gonna have one thing over here, which is J,
and we're gonna say m plus one. Now, I'll
tell you why we did this. And we also have,
which is K. And we said that as S,
i is equal to s, come back here, and we have
this IO. And it's going to be over here,
which is the starting value, just give me another
color over here, I'll just get a little darker.
Okay, so I have over here, which is right here.
And the second one, what we have is this mid,
we know that, okay, so other one we have is j
is equal to n plus one. So if I go back here,
we have this j is this over here. And we
know that this is endpoint right here,
he so you can see that this AI has to go in commit
all the way to the M, this is its last element.
And this j has to increment all the way to the end
portion here. So that's how we're going to compare
the values like two and three, which one is
similar to planted here, go and commit to two plus
seven. And then we're gonna say seven and three,
what is smaller, three smaller planted here, and
then put the rest. So that's the process what I'm
trying to implement to code, I have to map this
out. So that's why I'm using this diagram. That's
what we're doing. So we're going to have indicated
s, while let's have a while loop. And this is
how this process is going to go I which is that
value, what I told you, This over here is less
than or equal to m, and j is less than equal to E,
this process is going to go on. So if i less than
equal to m, and we have j less than equal to E,
we want some process going on. So if that buffer,
be you FF, er, FF er is E I, and then we have less
than equal to bu FF er sub j, if this process is
done, so if a buffer sub i is less than equal to
buffer sub k, then what we're going to do is a
sub k, that process what I was talking about,
that if it's less or equal than just copy it
inside of that, Kate, then the array which is over
here, we want to sort it out, so we're just gonna
copy here through buffer. So it's a bu FF, er sub
i.
So in the case, if it's less,
right, if it's less or equal,
and then we just increment is equal i
plus one, just what we did over there,
just what we did over there. So if that's
not the case, we'll just have an else.
And when I put something in here, so let me just
put over here, the case here is that a sub k,
a sub k is going to be over here, and it's going
to equal to buffer. So it's going to be buffer,
and then we're going to have sub j over here. So
we're gonna have this j in here, which is a sub k,
because if it's not the case, it's going to
be less, right. So it meaning if it's less,
but if it's greater than the J is gonna be there.
And then obviously, we're gonna have j being
incremented, instead of it being intermitted.
So we have that and we have k is equal to k
plus one. Let me just have that. There you go. And
now we have the condition here. So this is this
case over here. This is a while loop. And we
have another while after this condition. Now,
I'll tell you the reason why behind this.
So we have this while loop and after this,
we have two wild loops. Additionally, I'll tell
you the reason why we need those two. The thing is
that if we compare these two, like, suppose we had
this tool, and we had this three, we compare that
to was less. And then we incremented. It, we're
just doing plus plus don't we did, but the case
one that we came here at this 19 and 21, how these
come, this array just got full, all this was fully
remember this portion, but then we just appended
these last two inside of this, how do we do that
automatic process that automatic process was going
to be is going to be done through two wild loops,
we're going to be including, and that condition
is like if is less than good, or if j is less than
equal to eat. Now this is the two conditions and
look at this carefully. So while we say i is less
than or equal to m, so if this condition is like,
still there, like it's true, like it broke out. So
the process here is that these two will never
become false together, it's always going to be one
one of them and not the other. Right. So
if that case like Jays listening, he that
came and then after we still have is less than
equal m, what we could do here is that a sub k,
and this is the same scenario, what we did with
the example, a sub k is equal to we're gonna say,
buffer so that we got the thing from buffer, and
we said that as J. And what we do is basically,
actually, we're gonna have that set with I because
it's eye over here. And we're going to set that
with eye, and then we're going to do is, we're
going to increment i plus one, and we're going
to increment the K is equal to k plus one. And
if the other cases, they're like, while j less
than equal to E, we're going to have a sub k is
equal to buffer. And we're gonna have that as J.
Sub, there you go. And we have Jay Z going to j
plus one. And we have k is equal to k plus one,
it's just going to increment the K value.
And you already know where k is starting.
This is k right here. So this portion is K. And
j is going to go 1-234-567-8910. All the way
when it's done. So it just keep on incrementing,
you can see that j is over here is over there.
And that's the process going behind it. And then
once we're done with it, we don't want this extra
memory, we just delete it. So we just delete
our buffer and using this delete syntax, it's
basically we're going to deallocate it from the
memory. And that's it. Now let's just have this
additional function that we need is basically, I
think, so it's a printed, so Oh, I forgot my main
logic here. I mean, so this is mean, maybe I left
it up on the top, yep, that's a common mistake.
Okay, so just delete that portion here. And let's
just have a display function at the bottom here.
So at the bottom value, right here, let's have a
display function. So it's going to be called void,
we're gonna have a display, and we're doing is
basically having an array, just like the small
other ones, so have the size n. And we're gonna
have something which is going to be implementing,
like we have temporary, and we're going to have
that associated with a sub. What am I doing
x not actually that i is equal to zero, my dad.
So we're gonna have while i is less than n,
and then we're gonna say, console, output the
array value, array sub i, and put that comma here.
And then we have it just keep on incrementing
plus plus. And yeah, constant output here.
There you go. And now what we'll do is basically
run the code here. So get a random array again.
So let me just get this array, which is right
here, copy here, copy and paste it here.
And let's just change up the thing over here,
which is insertion or sword, we're going to have
Mr. G, Mr. G, Mr. g sort, merge sort. So let's
go back to our c++ compiler, c++, Mr. g, s,
o r t dot cpp, Ivan Oh, Mr. G, Mr. g, s, o r t,
and a compiled Mr. g s. o RT. There you go, viola,
110 and then 100 to whatever 293 and then
all of that, and sorted in ascending order.
So that was it with merge sort. And this is much,
much more faster as compared to any of the sorting
algorithms we've done so far. So even selection
sort bubble sort, Insertion Sort, even the
problem that we did in the beginning, because
those were of time complexity, old n squared
over n squared over n squared over n squared.
But this merge sort is somehow faster, because
it's doing the time complexity. In all n log of n,
so Oh, and then we have n, and then we have log,
and then we have that n inside of it. And this
is much, much more faster as compared to any of
the other sorting algorithms. Now, if you get like
a set of arrays from a text file that I could be
doing in my other videos, so stay tuned. For my
next upcoming videos in my channel, you're going
to be seeing that we're going to have a text file,
and we're going to be looking at comparing how
fast is this compared to other sorting algorithms.
Because if we have these O of n squared,
sorting algorithms, these are going to take much,
much more time as the input value increases, it's
going to exponentially exponentially grow. But as
compared to merge sort is just going to be fast as
lightning because it's in all and all n log of
n whatever complexity. So hope you enjoyed this
video, hope you liked it. And please make sure to
visit my channel which is called coding cleverly,
where I have so much content of c++, and I've done
data structures and algorithms. I have done object
oriented programming, done the basics, beginner
level, procedural programming, and I my my goal
is to complete data structures. And then after
that, I advanced to other project based videos
as well as new languages and technologies.
So make sure to subscribe to that channel.
And yes, thank you so much for watching. I really
appreciate the support. So thank you so much,
and thank you Free Code Camp for putting my
video on their channel. Really appreciate it.